AFF schleer le président du patronat
allemand aurait été exécuté en
France Espagne front commun de tous les
partis politiques pour soutenir le
programme économique du gouvernement
rugby l'équipe de France pass celle du
président 29 à 18 invité du journal
Bernard Lefort en 1980 il succédera à
rolp Liberman à la tête de l'Opéra de
Paris
Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonsoir
c'est donc grâce à un pompiste de Mulous
que l'enquête sur la mort de Monsieur
Schleyer le patron des patrons allemands
a avancé d'un pas maintenant les
policiers savent que l'Audi verte dans
laquelle on a découvert le corps de
Monsieur Schleyer se trouvait mardi
dernier à 8h30 à mulouse et les
enquêteurs sont persuadés que
l'exécution de Hans Martin Schleyer a eu
lieu en France peu de temps avant avant
ou après cet
instant tandis que des centaines de
policiers continuent de surveiller la
frontière et de quadrier nuit et jour
l'Alsace les enquêteurs s'efforcent de
reconstituer l'itinéraire de la voiture
où était retrouvé le corps de
hchleyer le témoignage d'un pompiste de
Mulous et semble-t-il pour l'instant le
seul point de l'enquête dont la police
puisse être certaine les policiers
semblent convaincus que le président du
patronat allemand a été tué en France en
plein air et à genou comme le commandant
du Boeing détourné de la Luftansa
l'autopsie a en effet dcolé des brins
d'Herb sur le visage de la victime et
des aiguilles de pain sur son costume
mais jusqu'à présent les recherches tant
sur le lieu de l'exécution que sur
l'endroit où hsleyer a été séquestré
n'ont rien donné la piste concernant une
ferme isolée de la Barroche dans le Hain
et qui aurait servi de cache au commando
s'est avéré fausse en attendant en
France comme en Allemagne les appels
lancés par la police pour une
collaboration de la population ne sont
pas restés vain pour cette seule journée
de samedi le commissariat central de
mulouse a reçu près de 200 appels
j'ajoute que des protestations se sont
élevées dans la population de Stuttgart
contre la décision du maire de la ville
d'autoriser l'inhumation d'Andreas Bader
et de deux de ses compagnons ses deux
compagnons mort en prison enfin la grève
mondiale des pilotes de ligne qui devait
avoir lieu mardi après l'assassinat du
commandant de bord allemand de l'avion
détourné cette grève a été annulée court
valdim secrétaire général des Nations
Unies a en effet promis que l'assemblée
gén s'occuperait très sérieusement et
très prochainement de la sécurité de la
navigation aérienne
internationale en France deux faits à
retenir dans le domaine politique la
Réunion tout d'abord du Mouvement de la
Jeunesse communiste à Villejuif qui a
été l'occasion pour lui de faire le
point des problèmes de la gauche comme
leurs aînés les jeunes communistes
défendent le programme commun et
critiquent le Parti socialiste j'ai
expliqué aux militants que les choses
pourvaiient changer en mars 78 à
condition qu'il fasse qu'il prennent
part à un effort extraordinaire que les
communistes mènent pour faire soutenir
leur politique faire pression et amener
le Parti socialiste à corriger sa
position il a viré à droite il faut
qu'il revienne à l'union de la gauche si
nous avons cette union de la gauche nous
pouvons changer vraiment les choses en
78 pour cette bataille les jeunes
communistes vont améliorer leurs
journaux le mensuel avant-garde va
devenir hebdomadaire dès le mois
prochain l'bdo des jeunes et des
étudiants communistes
clarté restera mensuelle et s'adressera
plus particulièrement aux étudiants
communistes la presse comme moyen de
combat politique était donc le thème de
la Réunion les 1000 délégués venus de
toute la France ont eu également
l'occasion de parler de la querelle des
état-majors de la gauche et de leurs
propres
aspirations ce n'est pas une querelle
d'étatmajor c'est quelque chose qui
détermine la vie politique qui développe
des
des sentiments
d'inquiétude d'angoisse même dans la
jeunesse qui espère pour pouvoir sortir
de de la crise pour pouvoir en finir
avec le chômage qui espère en une
victoire de la gauche qui crée les
conditions à ce qu'il y ait de vrais
changements ce n'est absolument pas une
une querelle c'est quelque chose de de
profond changer la vie réaliser une
union sur des bases claires c'est-à-dire
sur un bon programme sur la base du
programme commun 72 bien is aujourd'hui
c'est le débat que nous venons avec un
plus grand plus grand nombre possible de
jeunes et faire la clarté parce que vous
savez les jeunes on constate dans nos
discussions Nim pour la magouille
politique ils aiment que les choses
soient dit clairement simplement et
c'est de cette façon que nous
allons continuer et développer le débat
que nous avons lancé dans notre pays
avec tous les jeunes qui veulent faire
ça ch deè fait représentants de la
majorité et de l'opposition à la même
tribune ce weekend à Versailles pour
parler Europe la convention pour
l'Europe fait le point sur l'évolution
de la communauté et sur les perspectives
que lui ouvrira l'an prochain la
première élection du Parlement européen
au suffrage universel c'est l'occasion
aussi de réinsuffler un peu de vie à
l'esprit européen indispensable dans les
temps à venir comme le dit Monsieur
Louis le prince Ringuet qui préside le
mouvement européen est-ce que nous
allons pouvoir vivre donner à travailler
à nos ouvriers à nos à nos à au au
français dans 20 ans ou 50 ans regardez
le textile le textile actuellement il ne
peut plus tenir les chemises qui
viennent de de l'étranger de l'Est
asiatique et puis de l'Afrique sont au
tiers du prix français regardez les
constructions navales regardez Manu
France regardez tout ça tout ce qui est
sidérurgie métallurgie le Japon fait
beaucoup mieux on fait la même chose
avec un prix inférieur qu'est-ce que
nous allons faire il faut nous associer
si nous ne faisons pas l'Europe nous
serons trop petits nous serons bouffés
nous serons esclavesag nous deviendrons
esclaves des grands nous serons bring
balon comme ça et puis progressivement
notre influence diminuera je crois que
nous allons nous allons avoir des
nations je dirais qui sont
interdépendantes dans une communauté
c'est la communauté qui leur garantira
une réelle indépendance l'Europe est
considérée par le reste de de l'humanité
est compris par l'Afrique par les pays
du Maghreb et par l'ensemble des pays
africains qui ont signé la convention de
l'omé que comme une réalité ils aiment
mieux l'Europe que l'Amérique et que et
que la Russie soviétique l'Europe pour
moi il y a pas d'autre solution notez
que Raymond bar prendra la parole demain
à cette convention européenne un bref
regard sur le monde États-Unis d'après
le président Jimmy Carter un nouvel
accord sur la limitation des armes
stratégiques accord entre Moscou et
Washington pourrait être signé dans
quelques semaines le président américain
a affirmé que les perspectives étaient
bonnes de son côté Léonide bregniev
s'est montré un peu plus prudent tout en
reconnaissant qu'un certain progrès
avait été enregistré dans la bonne
direction critique des syndicats arabes
et africains réunis en ce moment à Alger
envers le gouvernement français après la
décision de Paris de suspendre
l'immigration familiale mais vous savez
que la section sociale du Conseil d'État
a donné un avis défavorable à cette
mesure le Conseil d'État statuera jeudi
s'il donne lui aussi un avis défavorable
le gouvernement modifiera son texte
injustifiable et insultant c'est la
réaction du kedorsé après les
déclarations du Premier ministre saraoui
selon lesqueles il y aurait des agents
secrets parmi les techniciens français
travaillant à Zerat le qu d'Orsa en a
profité pour lancer un nouvel appel au
gouvernement qui entretiennent des
contacts avec les auteurs de
l'enlèvement de 6 français à Zerat afin
d'obtenir leur libération Espagne front
commun de tous les partis pour le
redressement économique le gouvernement
s'est entendu avec l'opposition sur
toute une série de mesures visant à
lutter contre l'inflation
au palais de la Moncloa résidence du
Premier ministre espagnol le leader
socialiste fppe Gonzales comme le numéro
1 communiste Santiago carigo ont donc
abouti à une sorte d'union sacrée avec
le gouvernement pour le redressement
économique de
l'Espagne monsieur frag ribarn a
également donné son accord au nom du
parti de droite alliance
populaire gouvernement et oppositionign
tion comme le mal numéro 1 dont souffre
l'Espagne leur objectif désigné ramener
le taux d'inflation de 30 % fin 77 à 15
% un an plus tard le premier ministre
espagnol a salué l'effort de solidarité
et le sens des responsabilités dont ont
fait preuve les négociateurs ceci malgré
le désaccord qui est apparu sur le
projet gouvernemental de loi
antiterroriste critiqué par l'ensemble
des chefs des partis politiques le
projet a été purement et simplement
écarté Gaston de verre le maire de
Marseille n'est pas content sa Ville a
organisé un salon de l'OTO qui
visiblement a été boouté par les
constructeurs français c'est
inadmissible et même scandaleux a dit
Monsieur de fer en inaugurant le salon
qu'en période de crise les industriels
français n'aillent pas au devant de
leurs clients à moins a-t-il ajouté
qu'il méprise les Marseillais cela dit
chacun se demande ce que va devenir
l'automobile disons dans les 10 ans qui
vienent Gérard Merigot a mené son
enquête auprès des professionnels et
voici quelques éléments de réponse non
on ne va pas forcément vers une
révolution spectaculaire du genre
voiture électrique mais on va sûrement
vers des améliorations techniques pour
que la voiture consomme moins pollue
moins et ne fasse pas de l'homme son
esclave saturation on pourrait le croire
à aucun moment pourtant cette notion
n'entre en ligne de compte dans les
perspectives d'évolution de l'automobile
l'idée qui prévaut élimine toute
récession mais considère ce que l'on
appelle une croissance
raisonnable après le boom des années 60
où le rythme d'expansion était de 10 %
par an on écarte maintenant toute idée
d'aventure
industrielle la crise de 74 a ruiné bien
des illusions la conquête de l'Ouest
n'est plus à faire la véritable
croissance se situe à l'est c'est-à-dire
du côté du soleil levant les pays non
industrialisés étant maintenant les
objectifs de la survie ce de la 3è
guerre mondiale la guerre économique
l'expansion devrait être 3 3,5 % du
marché mais avec des amplitudes qui sont
qui peuvent être très fortes et
peut-être plus fortes que par le passé
mais ceci dit le signe sera positif à
quoi ressemblera l'automobile de 1995
est-ce que c'est à quoi elle ressemble
aujourd'hui ou est-ce qu'elle va évoluer
vers une tendance du modèle unique dans
une gamme écoutez c'est évidemment assez
difficile mais en gros on peut dire que
l'automobile de 85 ressemblera à
l'automobile actuel c'estàd diversifier
dans les gammes des constructeurs oui
diversifier dans les gammes des
constructeurs mais remarquez que la
diversification elle existe déjà en tout
cas en ce qui concerne les constructeurs
français et même on a remarqué que si
les Français avaient assez bien résisté
à la crise de 73 mieux que le
concurrents étrangers c'est que la gamme
des quatre marques françaises était déjà
très diversifié al vous dire ce que sera
le moteur en 85 il devrait être en gros
ce qu'il est actuellement c'est sans
doute pour les étapes ultérieures la fin
du siècle qu'on verra apparaître des
moteurs peut-être
différents l'évolution principale pour
les 10 ans qui viennent touchera
l'électronique et puis aussi et surtout
considéré aujourd'hui comme les agents
du gaspillage les moteurs devront
consommer moins de l'ordre de 20 % en
moins croissance raisonnable d'autre
part cela signifie que le parc
automobile français augmentera
régulièrement de 5 à 700000 voitures par
an pour cela les constructeurs spéculent
également sur l'expansion démographique
nous sommes 3 milliards d'hommes sur la
terre 3 milliards avec une saturation à
3 3 hommes par véhicule
ceci un parc d'un milliard et un par
d'un milliard de véhicules alors
qu'actuellement le parc global mondial
est de l'ordre de quelques centaines de
millions par conséquent nous avons
encore une certaine marge de
production sans aucune difficulté dans
les années qui
viennent une nouvelle fois donc toutes
les constatations que font les
spécialistes sont optimistes le pétrole
oui bien sûr disIl mais nous avons
aujourd'hui 30 ans réserve sans compter
ce que l'on trouvera d'ici là la
saturation du marché pensez donc
l'humanité ne cesse de croître quant à
l'urbanisme et bien il s'adaptera une
nouvelle fois il a l'habitude et puis
les pays pauvres ne sont pas encore
motorisés cet optimisme forçonné qui
semble par moment relevé de la méthode
Coué ne devrait tout de même pas faire
oublier que s'il l'avait pressenti les
constructeurs n'avaient pas anticipé la
crise de
74 André poletto meurtrier de sa petite
fille Yvon à Marseille a été vivement
prise à parti aujourd'hui par les
habitants d'un quartier de cette ville
où il s'est rendu en compagnie de la
police pour les besoins d'enquête les
incidents ont été vifs puisque les
gendarmes ont dû utiliser des grenades
lacrymogènes pour contenir la foule cela
pourrait rappeler un compte de fait des
temps moderne il était une fois un petit
village du Tarne déserté par ces jeunes
filles qui avaient préféré la ville à la
campagne pour les jeunes gens désireux
de se marier personne à l'horizon ne
pouvait satisfaire leur cœur alors ils
ont pris leurs plumes et ont tourné leur
regard vers l'île Maurice de jeunes et
jolies mauriciennes sont donc venu dans
le village que s'est-il passé ensuite
regardez Monsieur et Madame Bousquet se
sont mariés il y a 3 ans elle vient de
l'île Rodrig lui est agriculteur dans le
Tarne il y a encore 10 ans les écoles
fermaient les villages mourent les
filles quittaient les campagnes attiré
par la ville il a donc fallu trouver une
solution pour les hommes à marier et
grâce au mariage réussi de l'un d'entre
eux ils sont une trentaine qui ont
cherché femmes parmi les jeunes filles
des îles de l'Océan
Indien quelle impression avez-vous
ressenti lorsque vous avez rencontré
votre futur mari pour la première fois
mais comment dire
ça c'estàdire on avait les photos on se
connait presque même sans savoir vous
aviez correspondu longtemps on écrit on
voit des photos comme ça et en se voyant
est comme si on est déjà vu
quoi comment avez vous réagir lorsque
vous avez vu sa photo pour la première
fois comment avez-vous été accepté par
la famille de votre mari oh assez bien
oui ns sont pas nombreux la famille mais
ça a bien marché oui tous sont gentils
avec moi et peut-être si ça marche pas
comme ça j'aurais pu revenir chez moi
parce que le billet payé à retour
c'était facile de revenir c'est lui qui
avait payé le billet oui c'est lui
j'aimerais que vous me parliez un peu
d'elle c'est une femme qui qui pour moi
est bien
quoi quelles sont ces qualités ah
les
comment vous vous êtes adapté à la la
vie française au début céit un peu dur
et puis après je suis habitué surtout le
froid le climat il fais plus froid que
là-bas et le travail aussi c'est plus
dur vous voyez j'ai cout là-bas ici faut
s'occuper des bêtes et il par le champ
aussi il faut
aller aujourd'hui il fait beau c'est
presque l'heure de dîner là non et ben
bientôt
ça va être midi on pas fin
aussi les jeunes tout ça tout ça par
bien les mais son désert campagnes on
ferme les écoles on ferme tout tout le
monde la ville c'est parce que la vie
est trop à la campagne pas plutôt je
sais pas est trop autre fois oui mais
maintenant les machine mais je sais
pasil
c'est je sais rien
moi pour vous
l'expliquer vous regrattez pas la vie
que vous avez eu vous si vous la
regrattez c'est-à-dire que je l'ai eu
bien dur et je pens bien autre fois il
fallait faire à la main est-ce que vous
êtes une femme heureuse
oui
c'estàd oui mais comme je vous dis des
fois quand je pense à mes parents je
suis pas tellement heureuse dans ce
moment là mais c'est pas souvent à part
de ça oui je suis heureuse le mari n'est
pas
méchant quel
chose malgré la chaleur des foyers
qu'elles ont trouvé en France certaines
de ces jeunes femmes ont eu à souffrir
de problèmes de racisme les gens de la
région en particulier ils ont ils ont
critiquer énormément principalement
certaines personnes sans sans réfléchir
au problèm
et parce que votre femme était d'un
autre pays et peut-être parce que il
traite les les gens noir comme comme des
sauvages vous voyez c'est ça c'est ça le
problème jusqu'à maintenant c'est ça le
problème puis ensuite certains quand ils
ont réfléchi ils ont
vu il y a un climat jalousie qui qui
s'estore ensuite est-ce que vous avez
peur de du jour où le votre enfant ira à
l'école oui c'est ça le problème parce
que je commence à avoir peur attention
que les gens ils parlent ils disent que
toi tu as une maman noire et et tu n'es
pas comme les autres quoi c'est ça le
problème est-ce ils ont dit déjà vous
voyez quand l' enfin il était né ils ont
même dit on va voir le petit singe alors
est-ce que vous êtes heureux tous les
deux maintenant si a pas de
raison neu essais rien de moins les
spectateurs du Parc des Princes et les
téléspectateurs dans Tn2 ont été gâtés
pour la rencontre de rugby entre
l'équipe de France qui a gagné le grand
schlem et une sélection des autres
équipes étrangères que l'on appelle le
15 du président et la France a battu le
15 du président sur le score de 29 à
les Français maillot bleu à gauche sur
votre écran mais c'est l'équipe du
président qui va pourtant marquer la
première regardez bien replay Le Grand
anglais qui file le petit côté qui voit
evvans les légalois qui lui donne et qui
va marquer evvans CR transformera l'ESS
6 pour l'équipe du président les
Français ne vont pas tarder à réagir
regardez la balle VO de m à main et
ponceau non ça c'est une foute sur M est
ouverte il va y avoir en
un coup franc joue la main par for la
balle va voler main en main et arrivera
jusqu'à ponce quia marqué entre les
poteaux et Rome
transformera regardez bien c'est vite
fait voilà 6 pour la France ensuite
Richard pour l'équipe du président puis
Mar pour la France et Rome un drop enfin
la 38e
minuteon prend la balle
file fait le trou et voit conqu
l'Africain du Sud qui prend la balle qui
va marquer un ESS et à la mi-temps
l'équipe du président mènera par 14 à
13 la seconde mi-temps est française les
Français sont maintenant à droite et la
passion
monte balle prise par
Gilbert mais ouverte jou par
palmier AG qui arrive comme un boulet
qui marque un essai que Rome
transformera 19 pour la
France à la 20e minute sur une BAL
quelque peu cafouillé ardemment
disputé po surg et marque Rome
transforme France
25 et à quelques minutes de la fin
Willer marour 25 à 18 et voici le plus
bel ESS de la partie AG a percé a donn à
lati France 29 vous allez revoir au
ralenti d'une pureté merveilleuse on en
voie peu des comme ça 29 à 18 ce sera le
score final de ce beau match sans enjeu
mais ceci explique peut-être
cela avec nous ce soir Bernard Lefort
qui je le suppose est un homme heureux à
double titre en tant que directeur du
festival d'exen Provence puisqu'on
reprend La Traviata à Paris que vous
aviez monté a ex en Provence avec quel
succès et puis parce que vous avez
appris comme nous cette semaine que vous
alliez succéder à Liberman à la tête de
l'Opéra de Paris alors je voudrais
savoir ce que vous allez faire entre la
date de votre nomination cette semaine
et la date de votre prise en fonction
c'est en 1980 qu'est-ce qui va se passer
et bien je bénéficie évidemment d'un
lapse de temps rare je crois dans
l'histoire du tê lyrique je dois cet
avantage considérable à deux personnes à
Monsieur Liberman qui a expliqué que le
temps était un facteur nécessaire autant
que l'argent et au ministre monsieur
dorano qui a bien voulu qu' mais vous
allez travailler avec Monsieur Liberman
pendant ce temps-l ù vous allez laisser
faire à partir d'un certain moment vous
allez entrer en jeu qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ah je n'ai rien à faire avec la
gestion de l'Opéra jusque au mois de
septembre 1980 donc vous réfléchissez je
vais d'abord préparer la programmation
et les distributions des trois saisons
qui me sont confiées et j'ai en plus
l'intention dès le mois d'octobre
1978 de prendre la direction
personnellement de l'école de champ que
nous entendons créer à l'intérieur de
l'Opéra j'aurai 2 ans pour diriger
personnellement cette école après quoi
je nommerai un directeur au moment où je
prendrai mes fonctions d'administrateur
Bernard Lefort vous héritez d'un opéra
prestigieux on le sait grâce à la
politique exceptionnelle menée par Rolf
Liberman mais on l'a dit aussi une
politique qui coûte cher alors j'ai
l'impression qu'on va vous demander de
garder ce haut degré artistique de
diminuer les coûts et d'élargir un peu
le les spectateurs alors est-ce que
c'est possible on m'a demandé de
maintenir ce niveau artistique on ne m'a
pas demandé d'en diminuer le coût ah le
coût de l'Opéra de Paris est
considérable il est proportionnel à son
succès il n'est pas plus cher que lacala
de Milan où le métropolitain opéra on
m'a demandé par contre et ça sera mon
affaire de trouver les solutions
d'augmenter en effet son exploitation
j'ai mes idées là-dessus mais vous
comprendrez qu'il est trop vite pour
vous lire lesquels j'ai cru comprendre
que vous disiez que le coût était était
pas supérieur à celui d' lacal de Milan
mais je crois qu'à Coven Garden à
Londres les places sont beaucoup moins
chères pour une qualité artistique que
qui également excellente non il est très
difficile de comparer ces deux maisons
qui ont des exploitations très
différentes et des prix de reviens très
différents le Palais Garnier est un
théâtre extrêmement coûteux de par sa
vétuseté de par son fonctionnement
difficile common Garden est un théâtre
plus maniable plus léger qui demande
beaucoup moins de personnel y y
aura-t-il une nouvelle salle de
construite pour l'Opéra de Paris je
crois que on a compris sa nécessité mais
j'espère qu'on comprendra aussi la
nécessité de le préparer bien il ne faut
pas que ce projet soit réalisé à la hâte
et qu'on nous dote d'un bâtiment qui ne
soit pas utilisable dans le futur pour
le public qui ne va pas à l'Opéra de
Paris l'Opéra de Paris disons que c'est
une maison o il y a eu de sérieux
problèmes récemment avec les syndicats
notamment alors est-ce que vous êtes
assuré d'une paix sociale ou est-ce
qu'il va falloir encore renégocier
quelque chose je ne peux rien préjugé on
n jamais assuré d'une paix sociale tout
ce que je peux dire c'est queayant
l'intention de maintenir la qualité de
l'Opéra et si c'était possible de
l'augmenter encore et ayant
parallèlement l'intention de faire tout
ce qui sera en mon pouvoir pour que tous
les personnels qui travaillent à l'Opéra
se voient très justement rétribuer de
leurs efforts je peux espérer que la
paix sociale de l'Opéra se maintiendra
sans nous dévoiler quel sera votre
politique artistique est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quel sera le premier
spectacle que vous montrez sous votre
règne en 1980 je l'ai décidé cet
après-midi que j'ai passé à la biblièque
l'opéra ce sera un opéra de Ramo merci
Bernard Lefort revenons et reparlons si
vous voulez bien de de La Traviata c'est
une coproduction entre plusieurs opéras
de province notamment Bordeaux et le
Capitol de Toulouse mise en scène par
George Lavelli dans le rôle de la
Traviata Sylvia SAS La Traviata qui
n'est autre que la dame au camélia revue
par Verdi à sa création l'œuvre fut un
fiasco depuis les amateurs de Pra ont
bien changé d'avis
regard
a
al
signora
altro
Marto
la
ed
neurea sempre
la
vous pourrez voir l'intégralité de cette
Traviata vous l'avez vu très jolie sur
Antenne 2 prochaine de mots sur le temps
pour terminer ça se rafraîchi et surtout
ça se couvre il y aura beaucoup coup de
pluie demain avec des orages des ardenes
aux Alpes et à la Corse ailleurs le
temps sera variable vous pourrez compter
sur quelques
éclairc fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi vous retrouverez Hervé
Claude pour les dernières nouvelles vers
23h30 bonne soirée avec Antenne